more than a dozen good Samaritans sprang
into action risking their own lives to
save a passenger trapped inside a crash
SUV in California see these strangers
obviously all coming together to try and
keep this SUV from overturning they were
helping the driver who's dressed in
orange while an injured person was still
in the backseat it happened Wednesday
after the SUV jumped the curb slammed
into a large tree and started smoking
one of the group who rushed to set help
everyone said everyone's instincts just
kicked in
my friend actually told me Mike you got
to go out there and they need your
muscles the first thing that came to my
mind and also to everybody too was just
you want to help and someone is in need
and of help and you just run I mean
despite concerns that the SUV might
explode the group was able to get the
vehicle upright and pull the trap
passenger to safety when a car is
smoking there's a risk you just don't it
might blow up so they were you know they
were taking a risk there that was I love
people jumping into action I just wish
that this is an immediate danger if only
we jumped into action just on GP right
right you know what it's really great
about that video is you can hear
everybody you know all together exactly
really good